on May 17th 2022 a pelis County
Sheriff's deputy Shelby Elise kago was
fired after she was arrested on a drunk
driving charge past midnight the
incident occurred late at night at about
1:00 a.m. when kago was pulled over by
police at the intersection of 108th
Avenue North and 4th Street North in St
Petersburg when the officer approached
her kago attempted to use her status as
a count talk her way out of the
situation I'm a pelis County Deputy okay
do you have your license
registration
no you don't do you have your ID on you
um do you have any weapons on you no as
kanago looked around for something to
identify herself with the officer
explained to her why she got pulled over
I live right there I get that but I
pulled you over cuz you were flying past
everybody and you were cutting no I was
just driving okay when I was calling
dude at this point you were going like
56 and a
40 you were flying no I was not flying I
was just do you have your registration
with your name on it or anything well
this car is not mine so okay after
looking around for a while kogo finally
found her driver's license and handed it
over to the officer the officer went
back to her patrol vehicle to run it
through the system more police officers
showed up at the scene waiting for the
first officer's Direction on how to move
forward with this traffic stop a few
minutes later the officer returned from
her vehicle and asked kogo to step out
to the side of the road so she could
conduct some standard field sobriety
tests kogo was extremely reluctant to
perform the test and tried to talk her
way out of the situation but it didn't
work the officer began listing off all
the reasons why she believed that kogo
was impaired and said that she wasn't
going to let her off without finishing
the
investigation no you have to go over it
again I am showing what exactly you have
bloodshot watery eyes you have slurred
speech you have a strong but I'm wearing
contact lenses okay you have a strong
odor of alcohol coming from your breast
but I'm wearing I have okay all right as
I said I'm just conducting investigation
at this point I want to give you every
opportunity you're saying that you're
that you're fine I want to give you
every opportunity to show me that there
is no way in hell seeing that the
officer was not backing off kago finally
gave in and agreed to the sobriety test
but the results were not convincing all
I you do is just stand your feet
together and arms down your sides so
what I'm you to do is follow this red
light with your eyes don't careful with
your eyes don't careful that
is what I'm going you to do is follow it
with your eyes and your eyes only I
don't want you to move your head at all
okay if your shoes bothering you you can
take them
all that's too
fast
careful all right Sam you come up step
up to this line he ready kago was
eventually requested to undergo a
breathalyzer test the findings validated
the officer's initial concerns her blood
alcohol level was notably higher than
the legal threshold of 08 clacking in at
0.15 or even
more this led to conag Leo's arrest on
charges of driving under the influence
in Florida it's a given that if your ba
is 8 or above you're considered unfit to
be behind the wheel with kano's BAC
nearly doubling that it underscored the
gravity of her decision to drive after
her arrest her association with the
pelis County Sheriff's Office promptly
ended in line with the Department's
standard procedure however her transfer
to the penales county jail went without
any problems and she was let go on her
own recognizance by the next Tuesday on
July 26 2017 a 43-year-old man named
William Gray rendered unconscious from a
severe car accident in cashet County was
admitted to Salt Lake City University
Hospital in Utah at the time Alex
wubbles a dedicated nurse since 2009 was
attending to patients in the burn unit
and was present when Mr Gray was brought
in however the situation took a
distressing turn when the police entered
the picture detective Jeff payt Keen to
test the patients blow for any elicent
substances approached nurse wubbles with
his request but she declined and
emphasizing that the hospital's rules
required official authorization
especially in the absence of a search
warrant from officer
pay hi can you protect me I've been
threatened to be placed under arrest by
this officer here I'm trying to prohibit
him from
drawing does not have a warrant for if
things still keep going the way they're
going I'm arresting her they can't
protect you for interfering with the
criminal investigation detective pain
didn't take this life and began to to
pressure W even threatening to detain
her he accused her of obstructing
illegal inquiry okay this is coming from
our leadership it's coming from M But I
either go away with blood and vials or
body and
toe that's my only choice up P this
young lady right here right now is not
free to go about her
business her watch command if she does
not allow me to go get a blood draw from
a guy up in the burning unit she's going
to jail wubbles trying to mediate the
situation explained she was only
following her professional duties and
that there was no need for aggression
yet pay was in no mood to hear her out I
don't know why you have to be so awful
and threatening I'm not here to imp I'm
just stating what is will happen we can
both say that sir I'm just I'm just a
nurse trying to protect the patients and
do what my hospital has obligated me to
do whether or not I'm trying to protect
him too later on Nurse wubbles printed
out a document that was signed between
the hospital and the police Police
Department about the hospital's policy
regarding patient blood
drugs hold on so I printed this off I is
when I was P the print off I have this
it says OB painting blood samples for
police enforcement from patients
suspected to be under the influence this
is something that you guys agreed to
with this Hospital the three things that
allow us to do that are if you have an
electronic warrant patient consent or
patient under arrest and neither of
those things the patient can't
consent he told me rep that he doesn't
have a warrant and the patient is not
under arrest after nurse wubbles read
out the document officer Payne again got
confrontational at which point her
supervisor Brad Wiggins who was on
speaker phone stepped in am I fair to
smize that Alex you're
[Music]
not
yeah I don't know I have no idea why
he's blaming me me I'm just representing
why are you blaming the Messengers sir
she's the one that has told me no yeah
but sir you're making a huge mistake
right now threatening a
nurse no we're done we're we're done
you're under arrest we're going we're
done
help IP ad she can sit in my car while
we're they coming this is unnecessary
wubbles was screaming and crying for
help as she was pushed out of the
hospital thrown up against the wall in
handcuffed the Hospital staff tried to
talk down pain but nothing seemed to
work a few moments later officer Payne's
Watch Commander Lieutenant James Tracy
showed up and told the handcuffed nurse
that their actions were completely
lawful under the circumstances I'm
telling you is we are not making a
mistakes okay I've done this for 22 plus
years I know what the law is when it
comes to search and procedure what you
have done because your bosses are
telling you to has been to prevent this
officer who was called out to do a job
to do his job that's obstructing Jud
okay is this person do you know is this
person a resident that we're trying to
get BL I have no idea I don't even know
another problem okay so you're why are
you involved in this you don't have
anything to do with it because I'm the
charge mer in the unit that he was
admitted my job is to help understand
where what we're supposed to do and
you're not you're not trying to
understand you're trying to sell us
that's all you're doing wubbles was
detained for 20 minutes before being
released without any charges the
incident was caught on Payne's body
camera and the hospital cameras the
footage was released to the public
thanks to wubbles lawyer Cara J Porter
sparking outrage all over after a 35-day
internal affairs investigation was
launched just 24 hours after the
incident Salt Lake city mayor Jackie
visovsky reported saying that both
officer Payne and Lieutenant Tracy
violated several department policies
during their interaction with
wubbles on October 10th Salt Lake City
police chief Mike Brown made made the
decision to Fire officer
Payne in a disciplinary letter the chief
wrote that detective Payne's Behavior
was inappropriate unreasonable
unwarranted discourteous disrespectful
and reflective of extremely poor
professional judgment especially for an
officer with 27 years of experience
which calls into question your ability
to effectively serve the public and the
department the department also made the
decision to demote Lieutenant Tracy to a
police officer 3 position which is two
steps down from his rank as lieutenant
nurse wubbles won $500,000 in a
settlement between the University of
Utah and Salt Lake City despite not even
filing a lawsuit not only that but she
became a champion for nurses and used a
portion of the settlement money she
received to help people get body camera
footage of incidents involving
themselves the patient involved William
Gray died two months after the
confrontation between the officer and
the nurse he had not been suspected of
wrongdoing a driver fleeing the police
had crashed into Mr Gray's truck
severely injuring Mr Gray and killing
himself
if you want to watch more videos of cops
facing the consequences of their actions
please subscribe to the
channel